yo what's going on guys mm-hmm I know I
said we do this with 130 but like we're
starting earlier today because as you
guys can probably tell I'm really really
tired right now i've been up since
yesterday at like eight or nine o'clock
working on the script for all I guess
working on the video for all videos for
all new all different Deadpool and all
new all different Wolverine so I mean
taking 20 min 20 minute videos you guys
takes hours it takes almost 17 hours to
make so I mean I'll make you guys 20
minute videos but in the process you're
going to have to deal with episodes of
comics a coffee like this sometimes
where I'm just really really really
tired but anyway so i'll do my best to
keep you guys entertained but but yeah
so yeah the posters in the back are from
Star Wars yes episodes 4 5 and 6 since I
think those are the best ones and then
of course you got the walking dead over
there and actually let me show you uh-oh
we pull up my real-time camera there we
go alright and then you got the Avengers
and then you got my YouTube plaques and
stuff like that and then you can't
really see them but on this wall over
here are what am I thinking episodes 1 2
and 3 so but that's where that's where
all those come from and then on the back
wall over here on this side
you've got the incredible hulk picture
that i had the tony stark picture that i
had and then there's the plaques of
Captain America detective comics amazing
spider-man and Superman did i watch the
Deadpool movie will fail they know I
didn't watch the Deadpool movie will
fail video I try to stay away from
negative stuff like that what do you
think of that man you rubble coming out
I actually didn't know about I don't
even know about auntie rope it is to be
honest I haven't had time to read it to
even look it up and see what it is
what's going on stool in there but um no
I don't know I didn't know what Batman
you're up here's what is that I'm kind
of curious let's look that up real quick
Batman Europa
oh okay apparently it was announced 11
years ago and it's just now coming out
those who got you were coming in I
apologize if I'm under the weather but
i've been up since like eight or nine
o'clock yesterday making writing the
scripts out and working on the video for
Deadpool and Wolverine so what I think
what happened to Joker and justice
league dark side Wars I would say that
the Joker Joker was one of like the
original gods like an original evil
entity I am exhausted I'm you know I'm
even when I first started this I was
telling people the people who first
showed up that like I've been up since
eight or nine o'clock yesterday working
on the scripts for all new ok you know
what I'm not in the mood block that guy
no I was i've been up since eight or
nine o'clock eight or nine a.m.
yesterday working on the scripts for all
new all different Deadpool and all new
all different Wolverine because it takes
you know upwards of 17 hours to make a
20 minute video so yeah like that's uh
that's why I've been up so late but
there why i'm so tired because you know
i don't have time to take a nap I got to
get a video up tomorrow like I don't
have time to take a nap or anything like
me my girlfriend broke up because I
don't have time to do anything like I
haven't seen family and hardly forever
like this channel literally rules my
life that's why I started Rob explains
because that channels more fun for me
than anything else you know but yeah
from start to finish like it's about 17
hours like okay here's so here's all
right you know what let's explain this
callous explains the creative process
like the creative process for a comics
explain video so assuming that like I
decide to make a comic like well the
problem is people won't watch my videos
if they're not 20 minutes so or they or
I've got to go like I've got to look at
tons and tons of comments
complaining you know about a about a
video about it not being like 20 minutes
but anyway um it's so like so from start
to finish alright when it comes to a
video let's say that like only well
different Deadpool is a good example
only wall different Deadpool comes out
of Daniel ways run which means that I've
got to go back I think it's the anyways
run anyway the most recent run before
seeger wars which means i have to go
through and read every single comic from
the previous run of secret wars in order
to understand everything that's going on
from there it's reading the new one of
Deadpool which is a single issue so
that's not that big of a deal then I've
got to sit down then I've got to type
out like about a nine page script in
microsoft word for the video and then
yeah and then record the audio which
takes anywhere between 25 to 30 minutes
sometimes longer if I if I go through
and like edit out all the flubs and
correct our mistakes and things like
that adding the modifications to the to
my voice and all that kind of gets stuff
like that is that happens so that takes
about 25 to 30 30 minutes sometimes 35
minutes and then putting it together is
about another eight or nine hours on top
of that so yeah it takes about 17 hours
to make a single 20 minute long video so
that's why I'm almost always tired like
whenever you guys see me like what if I
do these comics and coffee Q&A s like in
six minutes or about a like 11 or 12
like it takes a long time to write those
out because it's not just like you know
type it out here's what happened it's
like the perspective of the character
and how everybody else views that
character and what's going on and going
through and talking about like the whole
history and all that kind of stuff and
so like man but yeah like every time you
scream and shout at me for not making a
20 minute long video it's because it
takes 17 hours to do it that's why so
it's because so so bear with me here
guys I'll do my best to keep this as
entertaining as I can but just realize
guys that every time you scream and
shout at me for not making a 20 minute
long video it's because it takes 17
hours to do it that's why so am I happy
with how secret wars to other 15 is
going honestly secret wars needs to end
Jesus hickman I love you man you write
great stories Marvel just cut the thing
loose you know like it's you know and I
get the Marvel Marvel basically
releasing them as they get them I mean
that's pretty much how it is like you
know they're they're releasing them as
they get them and yeah I use one for
unlimited and comiXology to know I'm not
hitting up the gym because I don't have
time but now there yeah like they're
they're probably releasing those stories
as they get them you know which is why
you know they're it's taking so long as
far as i understand it Hickman has
everything right now and it just takes
you know a Sawbuck you know I'd say a
wash to do the art because I mean you
got to think you know like with with the
20-something odd pages I mean it could
be pretty lengthy but you're talking
about i think issues eight and nine are
supposed to be like double length issues
so like you know 40 pages or something
along those lines like it's when did i
realize i had an epic voice when people
told me but
I'll continue with the ingestive series
when I get a chance um what I'll
probably start doing is well I'm going
to be sure when I continue the injustice
serious who's in all honesty like I did
that as an experiment you know and I
told you guys in the video you know I
told you guys at the start of that video
that if it was popular enough I would
continue in but it's not popular enough
on my standard of measurement or at
least I don't think it is let me check
and see cuz I haven't had a chance to
look at my analytics for a while but
yeah like where's injustice that you
guys are just going to see some real
time stuff going on right now this is
like straight up just how it goes uh
where is the injustice video okay well
that's not too bad yeah I may experiment
with another video we'll see what
happens but yeah the struggle of making
17 our videos and being exhausted all
the time and never being able to see
your friends and your family and your
girlfriend breaking up with you because
you never have time to hang out with her
yeah this struggle is real I assure you
but anyway yeah writing is absolutely
crazy anyway yeah so I made you I made
you injustice again but let's see
everything about sharing the load with
it apprentice oh I'm hiring an editor
that's what I'm hiring an editor because
I'll tell you guys right now like if I
didn't hire Sean like if I didn't bring
him on as an editor I probably quit
YouTube to be honest with you guys like
I probably would have left I would have
been like you know I can't do this
anymore i'm exhausted all the time I
don't have time for anything and like I
would have I would have quit so um yeah
so that that's why it's a good thing
that I'm hiring an editor because i love
doing like i loved making youtube videos
i love talking about comic books like
it's it's it's amazing you know it's so
fun it's just you know I just don't like
losing everything
like losing everything in the process
and the guys getting blocked I'd also
like the idea of being so busy in the
process or not having time for anything
so um but anyway are you going to cover
any of the dark side war one shots I'm
hoping to i mean i'd like to it what I'm
thinking about doing like here's here
some IDC schedule is probably going to
process they're probably going to
progress for the next few weeks I'm
probably going to make our probably
going to do an injustice video in a dark
side video every week a dark side war
video every week depending on how dark
side war does because if dr. not war
does i'm not going to keep it going
there's no point in like making you know
continuing videos that don't do well
like that's that's pointless so but uh
but yeah like you know if it does well
i'll probably keep it going but like
yeah so i'll probably do some more
injustice stuff so I so hopefully I'll
be able to get to like the one shots in
about a month or so so his ultimate
Peter Parker dead yeah ultimate Peter I
think so I'm pretty sure he died in the
multiversal collapse so do I read The
Walking Dead comics yeah I try to I
definitely try to let's see any more
vids on purple man jessica jones yeah
like i'll probably make some more videos
and I'm you know I mean yeah i'm not i'm
not really sure when it go with that
though because we've covered everything
between jessica jones and purple man so
how would you rate your video editing
skills are you proficient now or do you
still feel slow oh I'm proficient now
the problem is this just a tedious
process it's a very tedious process so
um
no I'm not at a video on the deep deep
web yeah the Green Lantern one shot is
amazing it's probably the best green
lantern story we've had since Jeff Jones
Green Lantern rebirth it's pretty
amazing no the short change intro isn't
coming back and I've told you guys it's
not coming back like I've told you guys
time and time again it's not coming back
so if Deadpool went against super super
man who do you think would win The Fury
from Marvel or Superman well that's two
different questions I've Deadpool win
against Superman Deadpool would probably
win he just keep healing until he
realized he could use kryptonite so
let's see loving the blue Marvel when
you're doing thoughts on doing a static
shock now I'm probably not gonna do
static shock but I'm glad you enjoy the
blue marble video did you ever use torn
sites no I don't do that I know that
people who do but I don't do that are
you going to do a video on Victor Creed
on the x-men um I haven't had a chance
to read the all-new x-men line yet like
most of the what's going on brandon i'm
glad you from Kentucky no I haven't had
a chance to read most of the most of the
all-new all different comics yet except
for like you know yeah I can't think
this morning with the exception of
Deadpool and Wolverine and spider-man
and Iron Man those the only ones I've
had a chance to read so like those I
think are pretty solid but I'm Paul I
mean I'm going to do more videos on the
only wall different mobile lineup but
yeah so Rob will you be doing a 13 hour
stream nah won't be doing a doing a live
stream watching jessica jones or dare
devil or watching jessica jones like I
did near double let's see does Asgard
and another Asgardian dimensions exist
we don't know that yet we don't know
where Asgard rests in the realm of
everything as far as we know the whole
the whole multiverse is ben reyes you
know the marvel universe has been
restored to a degree but marvel's
literally just rolling things out and so
until they tell us that Asgard exists we
won't know
so at this point I really can't I really
can't speculate I explain explanation
breakdown videos are hard because there
isn't much and reuse episode is
completely yeah that's uh let's see what
do you comics on website what do I use
what website do i use for comics
comiXology is my go-to if you could
write a Deadpool kills DC Howard
Deadpool kill Batman by shooting him
from a mile away literally like that's I
think that people would realize are you
rob from comets actually I think
Deadpool would realize how dangerous
Batman is and that he can't kill Batman
from like up close you know in an in a
fight in a straight fight so I think he
would just like shoot him from a mile
away but yeah I know it's lazy but that
would be like this the smartest thing
the most intelligent thing for him to do
don't tell ScrewAttack that yeah I got a
okay got a text message yeah I did check
out all the all different iron man we
have a video on all new altar of an iron
man i'm pretty sure so yeah it's pretty
awesome
um
you think Marvel will actually show
spider-man before captain america civil
wars us so we release I'm not sure I
doubt it to be honest I think they're
really holding on to that as long as
they can at least that's what I would do
anyway we power them let's see can you
cover the archie comics can you cover
Spider Island event can you cover manga
in general maybe you can bring frames to
help with comics explain can you do
whatever you need to do to keep making
20 minute long videos Rob um let's say
how I lost weight I doubt it but I
appreciate the compliment um what do I
like more jimmy johns or subway jimmy
johns by a long shot ah let's see this
we just started this about 10-15 minutes
ago I think so Batman god of knowledge
versus Joker god of laughter destined to
fight against one another for ya like
I'm pretty sure that's exactly what's
going to happen I got pretty sure Jeff
Jones is going to take Darkseid war in a
direction where like Batman and you know
the Joker are destined to fight against
each other for eternity so where do I
start when it comes to new 52 Superman
read the origins and then jump into
Superman truth like literally grab
secret origins number one which features
Superman and then just jump directly
into into Superman truth so issue number
God issue number one godlike issued over
35 i think was when jeff jones started
it oh this is a really cool model this
is a snow wolf limited edition so yeah
the new doctors tricky i wear the new
Doctor Strange to that one looks really
good
how do I keep up with all the different
comics and timelines as a person with a
bunch of knowledge on current hobbies
mind exploding and trying to digest
every video you make you know the great
work uh it's you know it's difficult but
yeah like that's yeah it's difficult
yeah yeah it's it's tough to do like
that's yeah it becomes kind of habit
after a while you know like you just see
things as they are and how they
transition you know like like you look
at everything in phases you know with
Marvel it was everything up until seeger
worse it was in phases and it was little
just story arts you know story arcs just
exist in phases and with with DC it was
crises you know every 10 years or so it
was a crisis you know and so it was
pretty easy to digest everything's for
me it was anyway so will you do anything
on earth 2 i'm a you know we'll see
what's up but do you believe how Jordan
is going to stop Batman from convert to
the Joker I hope not let's see yeah I
used Premiere Pro let's see finally
catching this live I wanted to say dude
you're awesome I appreciate it I feel
exhausted but I appreciate it like I
want to go to the store and get some
energy drinks and get gassed up for for
finishing out these videos so thoughts
on the addition of an issue 92 Secret
Wars well what they did is they took
seven and they split it in half to make
seven and eight and then they're coming
out with nine they just simply needed
more they needed more content like you
can literally I mean for those of you
guys who saw our recent video about
secret wars if you felt like it just cut
off at the end that's because it did
that's because the comic was cut in half
so you know um yeah I've heard about
home being in Ragnarok I'm actually
really excited and the reason why
they're doing that is because
originally it was ragnarok future it was
the original Ragnarok story featured
Captain America and Iron Man but because
they're going to be involved in civil
war they're using the incredible hulk
instead so what's probably going to
happen here is for those of you guys who
haven't seen who ever read thor ragnarok
it's a six-issue series and beyond
wearing pants is a six-issue series and
it focuses on literally Asgard coming
under siege at the hands of Loki so
that's probably what it's going to be
based on i'm pretty sure anything on
multi versity i could not wrap my head
around multi versity like it was nuts I
don't know what Grant Morrison's doing
one multiverse I have no clue I think
he's out left-field writing about I have
no clue what he's doing there what I
want to spite a woman TV show honestly
probably not yeah if you guys see
somebody asking how long this has been
going for just just throw it in there
and say that okay you know this guy's
annoy me and my wearing pants yes I'm
wearing pants he's asked that twice
anyway if you guys see somebody asking a
question you know how long has this been
going on for just type in real quick you
know how long it's been going on going
on for so thoughts on beta ray bill
making an appearance i'm actually really
excited beta ray bill is a really solid
character like I'm really interested to
see where he goes in the in the
cinematic yeah the Marvel Cinematic
Universe once it's confirmed i'm sure
you know once they release a trailer for
thor ragnarok if they feed your beta ray
bill then then we'll go with that but
you know i'm i'm actually pretty excited
at the moment so you can't hear me well
let's see
is my audio too low for you guys I feel
like it might be a little too quiet let
me know if it's a little too little too
low do you think we will get the watcher
back or stay with the unseen um I think
we'll probably just stay with nick fury
on the moon I don't think we'll get the
watcher back The Watcher I think would
be cool but no I don't think we'll get
him back so did you do a thor ragnarok
video yeah I made a video explaining
what Ragnarok is so when did you decide
to change my will explain the comics
when I was working on when I was making
videos about what I want to combine
videos on Marvel DC and a whole bunch of
other stuff so okay audio is fine also
cool that's funny how like like I asked
people like can you guys hear me well
and they like no you're fine you're good
I am good like I am amazing you're great
yeah the delay is little delay sucks the
delay between like what you guys see and
what I or what you guys type in what I
see is it's you know it's it kind of
sucks but I've never really got into
Gundam you know never really got into
the whole gundam series um I think it's
a cool concept you know I think the idea
of Gundam is interesting but now I never
really got into a per se let's see
you're a huge spawn fan yeah I have a
video about spawn on like the the first
arc basically that spawn about how it
all got started so so yeah that's that's
that's the video that i have that his
character uh let's see I'm sorry to hear
about your girlfriend well I mean people
it's not a huge deal I mean I've broken
up with women and I've been
with befores it's par for the course
it's just the reason why we broke up was
because I don't have time to do anything
because I'm making videos all the time
some nature of things am I going to do
any videos about valuing combination i
have a video about valuing comics let's
see are you excited about the ultimate
will be in almost all black team it
doesn't really matter to me so much
about their race as it is what the story
is going to be about like I'm really
excited for the ultimates because it's
going to be like a multiversal Avengers
team and we've never had that before the
only time we ever had that was during
because my brain is a combination of
adamantium and other elements well not
some really i guess but captain
america's shield is rather um it's a
camera is something about the chemical
composition or i guess the atomic
composition might go to composition of
vibranium or something like that it's
just it's just how it is in Marvel
Comics I can't offer a better
explanation and I'm sorry but anyway
I'll slay me what i was talking oh yeah
the multiversal avengers so the only
time we saw the multiversal avengers was
during god when was it Seager horse I'm
sorry time runs out and it was literally
team that was formed and sent into the
multiverse to find out what was going on
with a collapse of the multiverse this
will be the first time that we have an
Avengers team that will serve the
purpose of defeating multiversal threats
and so I'm actually really decided to
see to see how that goes so I'm looking
forward to it but let's see the ultimate
has Captain Marvel think it's an all
black team well like America Java this
Hispanic as far as I know so it's not
really an all african-american team it's
a it's just a multiversal Avengers team
I don't really look at things at races
percent you know look at things as you
know I don't look at the race of things
like I don't the one of the benefits of
being born in my generation in the
nineteen nineteen eighty-four and going
forward is that yeah fallout 4 is
actually really kind of boring to me but
one of the one of the things that's
you know one of the great things about
being in my generation you know to
sidetrack here for a second for the
whole Q&A my generation was born in an
era where race was not as big of a
factor as it used to be and so I was
raised in an atmosphere where you know
race was an issue if you chose to make
it that way it wasn't as though i ran
into it everywhere I went and so you
know that's the for me like when I look
at comics and things like that and let's
it's a book like blue marble that's
explicitly designed to to focus on the
concept of racism you know within the
historical context of the Marvel
Universe then I don't really worry about
race at all you know I figure there's
far more important things in this world
to worry about then the color of a
person's skin so who do you think the
best writer for Batman is my favorite is
probably Scott Snyder yeah I'd say
probably Scott's Scott Snyder is
probably the best consistent Batman
writer Batman has had a lot of like
writers throughout the years and a lot
of people have done a lot of different
stories but i would say that in terms of
consistent consistently good
storytelling Scott Snyder is probably
the best one but i would say so yeah i'm
only 31 guys I'm not that old when do
you when do we get you to talk about
Metal Gear I'm if I talk for if I talk
about Metal Gear it'll probably be on
Rob explains so now I have and I didn't
read Thor's no I don't read was it good
yes or maybe hyping it up any plan to do
the walking dead story arcs like no way
out with an egg and casting announcement
all the walking dead videos are going to
be on on Rob explains so best that's
what that channel is the videos that
aren't doing like let the videos aren't
doing wildly popular here on on this
channel are being folded over and
condensed down to rob explains to see if
popularity exists over there because the
audience that i have here like for
whatever regional of white like Star
Wars is a really good example Star Wars
is consistently like one of the top
selling comic books right now but every
time I do new videos on Star Wars nobody
watches them on here like nobody cares
about Star Wars on here and so you know
so I it's my name's Rob not wrong but
nobody watches the one here so i just
stopped doing videos about Star Wars the
same thing with the walking dead the
walking on oh I know the word there were
a lot of you guys that really like the
walking dead but there weren't enough
people watching it that it was
beneficial to my channel so i stopped
making us at making those videos you
know because my goal is to grow my
channel you know not to force my channel
to stagnate because it's not growing so
but anyway so um rob is awesome yeah
Jeff Jones doing Aquaman again yeah yeah
like I'm public going to start reading
Aquaman again like new vida to Appa man
so any opinion on wally west and him
being sidelined okay so here's here's
the kicker like my videos are more for
like faction anything else and so i
usually try not to offer my personal
biases or non biases on on the
uncharacteristic that the only time that
I would ever really do that you know is
if I'm if I'm thinking like you know
here's my reason on why I don't think
this story is that great or here's my
reason on why I think that story is good
but that's about the extent of it with
wally west i would he be honest with you
guys the wally west new 52 sucks like
that's not the wally west i know that's
that's the new version of the while us
and maybe they did it because you know
for the sake of diversity maybe they did
it because
they have been going through and you
know they just want to try something new
but that's not the wally Western I'm
used to the Wally Weston I really like
is the pre flashpoint Wally West and so
I don't think that Wally West is going
to come back to the new 52 continuity um
but but yeah like you know that's I've
been reading contest of Champions a
little bit it's okay it's not the worst
thing ever but it's pretty interesting
vidya so what am I liking best about
all-new marvel iron man is a really
solid story let's see what else
spider-man's decent spider-man's never
really been interesting to me so um you
know he's okay to me but he's never
really like you know caught my fancy per
se they see I mean Ultimates isn't out
yet I don't think dental is actually
really entertaining to be honest and
they have the Deadpool Heroes for Hire
which is like like mad cap is one of the
characters which I think bidding is
doing a video on madcap but but i'll
probably do a video on like Deadpool's
Heroes for Hire like who those
characters are you know because if you
don't know it'd be really weird but
anyway um why you're spider-man being
hated on so hang on by somebody I think
he's really being hated on it's just
I've never really cared for spider-man
spider-man's stories it's my mind as a
character so let's see what is contents
of Champions is it more geared to the
game yet causes of Champions is
basically like a comic book counterpart
to the video gamer to the to the mobile
game so if you're playing the mobile
game then contents the champions iconic
will tie into it it'll be a cuts it's
like like dcs injustice is a really good
example um did justice was a video game
DC launched a prequel comic and became
stupidly popular and so you know
Ultimates is out already okay I didn't
realize this is what happens when you
spend when you don't have time to do
anything to make videos like you don't
you don't get a chance to keep up with
all the other
so um but yeah like and justice was the
same way you know like and justice was
um was a video game then they made a
prequel about it and became really
popular and then it turned into a huge
series so let's see it's gotten really
good reviews and it has one of my
favorite Marvel's one favorites Black
Panther yeah yeah like Ultimates is it
looks like it'd be pretty solid so let's
see ultimates came out and established
that the multiverse is back yeah well
multi like that what that was the case
like when they announced the ultimates
they established the multiverse was in
existence because of the fact that it
was going to be you know because there
was going to be a multiversal Avengers
team I was going to be the basis behind
it so why is region in this new universe
I'm not really sure I guess to be folded
over as a villain that could fight
against Peter Parker that seems to be
the case so
no I never read secret six so what
happened what happened to the Phoenix I
don't know as far as we know Scott
Summers died and the Phoenix forces may
be just out there I mean that's that
hasn't been explained yet you know again
guys until that stuff comes out in
comics I can't offer an explanation on
it because I don't know I don't know the
answer to that question so the problem
is we're in the Rin that's kind of like
when this dead band we're in this dead
zone Secret Wars hasn't finished but all
new all different Marvel isn't covering
the time between the end of cigars and
when all new all different level starts
and so there's literally this huge giant
black hole in the middle of Marvel's
continuity at the moment where we have
no clue what happened like that's that's
the problem with you know question why
didn't secret war single wars do not
animal I'm with Benny I think that
Marvel originally wanted to weaboo their
continuity and then decided not to at
the last minute so let's see yeah that
is one of the things that are normally
when people were like like we want you
to make videos like people when people
would post comments like everybody wants
you to make a video like we all want to
see videos about Star Wars we all want
to see videos about the walking dead and
then when I made them like not very many
people watch them so let's see
anyway uh what did you think happens and
then what do I think happens to that
time yeah how do I think Secret Wars
ends um honestly I think sick of wars
ends with dr. doom giving up I think
Secret Wars ends with dr. doom
voluntarily IPS in his power and setting
everything back to the way it used to be
like I think that's how it ends to be
quite frank or the very least recreating
everything to the Utopia that it was
supposed to be you know because remember
Stephen strain was making the argument
that you know there was no way to go
back there was no way to make things the
way they used to be and the marvels in
the Marvel Comics you know it was
impossible to recreate you know we using
the via the power of the honors it was
impossible to recreate what had been
destroyed and so the only thing that
could be done was to create a new
variation of everything but doom chose
not to do that instead he decided to
create a he decided to create if you
want to get a time runs out read
jonathan hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers instead dr. doom decided to
create battle world as like a place of a
place of testing and what ended up
happening is you know battle world came
into fruition and it was a really dark
place and so what I'm thinking is going
to happen is Reed is somehow going to
get with doom talk to doom whatever the
case may be but he's basically going to
convey to do but like you've got to make
things the way they're supposed to be
and so doom is going to we like reset
reset the whole universe or the whole
multiverse and make it the way it was
supposed to be as opposed to the way it
is the way it was for so basically like
dooms going to make the marvel universe
as it exists now so um yeah Marvel
should have definitely done a reboot
like they really should have rebooted
everything
well I ever finished explain the
Infinity worst oil on probably not
because that video didn't do very well
that's a kicker guys you know here's the
thing i know that there have been
stories that i've started that a lot of
you guys really really enjoy and that's
fine you know the issue here is that
when you're growing a youtube channel
when you are building a youtube channel
there's a difference between doing
things that will grow your YouTube
channel and things that won't and if
you're trying to grow a YouTube channel
you literally have to try different
things that's why I've started series
and then quit those series halfway
through because it's it's melting pots
it's trying different things it's seeing
what works seeing what doesn't work and
there have been series that I've started
like the walking dead serious like
infinity war where I pick them up to see
how they would do to see if they would
become popular and continue to grow my
channel and they didn't and so I stopped
doing them that's the nature of YouTube
guys you know it's it's trying different
things and trying to grow my channel and
that's that's why you know you guys will
see a serious start and then you'll see
it stop it's literally just trying
something new it's seeing you know
whether something will be successful
it's the nature of YouTube is how
YouTube works you know is how you grow a
channel if I were to not do that if I
were to you know what if Carlo madness
reacted one of my videos it'd be pretty
awesome if I didn't do that if I went
through and I started making videos on
things that only a small percentage you
know only the most hardcore of you care
about then it would cause my channel to
stop growing and my channel would start
to fail and that's not good so that's a
really bad thing no I don't watch
supernatural I watch like the first
couple seasons but then I just didn't
really enjoy what they were doing with
it so yeah really kind of you know said
that you know I really kind of said
really kind of a lot it was really kind
of a habit during those videos
which new villains do you want to see in
the MCU see really the only one new
villain that I want to see in the MCU
and that's Robert Reynolds the void I
want to see this entry in the MCU one
robbed too many things to do yeah that
too many irons in the fire is what it is
like that's why I've had to hire an
editor so but then again that's why you
guys will see me you know moving away
from old stuff that's why you guys see
me doing the most popular things because
that's how you grow a channel you know
that's how you grow a YouTube channel
that's how it goes so yeah I'm making a
living on YouTube you know but but
that's that's the issue and coming from
the perspective of those people you know
their mentality is oh I really like this
Rob needs to keep doing it you know and
they may be one of like five or six
people who really enjoyed it and who
really liked it but you know ultimately
it is you know I'm in the business of
growing a YouTube channel you know this
is what I do for a living you know and
it doesn't make any sense to to mess
that up it doesn't make any sense to
screw that up so you know that's that's
really the way it is you know but uh
anyway why does Marvel hate Mary Jane um
I don't think Marvel hates Mary Jane
Watson no I don't watch supernatural
Marvel doesn't hate the pedo a Peter
Parker Mary Jane Watson here's okay so
here's a deal with a Peter Parker and
Mary Jane Watson situation all right
when Joe casada he was the
editor-in-chief he had control over the
creative process and Marvel you know his
word was law and Marvel and the issue is
like for him he wanted to take Peter
Parker back to the way he used to be and
so he did yeah we had a we had mr.
Sunday movie we had James on Emma sewed
of the podcast but um anyway um he he
basically like you know got rid of
the whole mirrors like he cut it loose
with one more day he had one more day
commissioned by J michael Straczynski
and ended it into that marriage the
problem is that's like a taboo topic in
Marvel that is the black sheep of the
spider-man universe and it's easier to
simply just not go there than it is to
try to fix it you know it's one of those
things that if you fix it you don't you
make it worse so that's you know that's
kind of the problem
but
no he answered before that he doesn't
like Gotham it sucks how can you you
don't need to say anything like that you
know that's that's a crappy thing to say
like don't insult somebody because
they're because their opinions differ
from yours that's is that's a dumb thing
to do and that will get you banned on my
channel like I'm never okay with
insulting other people are putting other
people down because their opinions are
different than your own like that's
completely unacceptable to me so um
let's see if you could write the century
what would you do with the character um
that's a good question that's that's the
problem with him is what do you do with
that character honestly I probably
couldn't think of a good story with his
character I mean you know I probably
couldn't think of a good story about him
at all you know because he was a
character who was really powerful who
had schizophrenia but you know I mean he
was he's so incredibly powerful that
he's like he's like Franklin Richards
you know what do you do with a character
who's so powerful that he can fight a
fully like him fight a full ian race
Hall to a standstill what do you do a
character like that who do you have him
fight you know could you have him have
him deal with I mean that's that's
that's kind of the issue so moon out his
marbles Batman to a degree um what
Marvel does with characters like DC is
they literally take different aspects of
those characters and split them up so
like Superman is split up into several
several different characters of marvel
comics batman is split up into several
different characters in Marvel Comics
that's kind of how they do their thing
so
do you want to see Adam warlock in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe definitely I'm
hoping they do them well though like I'm
hoping they do them pretty solid so
let's see why spectrum portrayed as a
black woman and in Mighty Avengers whoa
crap i missed that well I can't find
that question again now the issue is not
that Marvel fears change the issue is
that while has a fan base you know is ok
it's like my youtube channel is a really
good example there were people who were
here originally with my youtube channel
when when I first launched and when I
started changing stuff you know when I
took videos and condense them down from
20 minutes shorter they were like well
most like i watch this anymore because
it's different from what I'm used to and
I don't like things that are different
you know um there are there were people
when i change the name from Marvel
explained at connors explained left they
were like no this should be a channel is
only based on Marvel Comics you
shouldn't don't bring do you see here
because i don't like DC there were
people who were adverse to me treating
this like my own youtube channel as
opposed to you know somebody else's
youtube channel and in Marvel is the
same way Marvel has fans who are casual
who just like reading about Iron Man and
they'll never read another character
they just like reading about iron man
there are some who show up in there and
they just want to see what the hype
about comic books is and they'll
literally just grab a random Marvel
comic and read it and then never buy
another comic book again um there are
people who are diehard fans and don't
ever want to see things change you know
who are like Peter Parker is spider-man
and that never needs to change and all
the stories that have ever existed never
need to be wiped out they need to stay
there you know and none of those people
are wrong you know they just have
different perspectives but you know is
it's just you know with DC it's doing
reboots they demonstrated that with
doing reboots the idea is that you can
effectively bring in a whole new echelon
of readers with Marvel you know they've
never really done a reboot for and so
they're effectively keeping all this
continuity going which is good and bad
it's good because you know the fans that
have been reading what comics forever
keep the continuity that they wanted but
it's bad because there's no reboot here
there's no fresh place to start from you
know if someone walks luck so to me and
says hey Rob where should I start with
with all new all different spider-man my
answer is superior spider-man from like
last year or the year before from two
years ago and then the question is well
I thought it was all new all different
Marvel it's like well it's called that
but it's not all new and it's not all
different it's just Marvel so you know
that's that's kind of the issue you know
it's it's it's one of those you know
it's one of those those weird things you
know in in the realm of comics you know
with reboots with crises the DC does
with a new 52 fans can say what they
want to you know they can they can
scream and shout they can stomp they can
jump it down they can talk about how DC
is not catering to their fans but at the
end of the day DC pulled in a ton of new
fans with new 52 they both of their
ranks you know quite quickly because it
was literally if you want to know about
Superman just start here this issue
number one actually comics number one
you know Superman number one that's all
you needed to start with Superman and
fans love that you know perspective fans
had a fresh place to start older fans
didn't like it but DC wasn't catering to
those older fans because they knew those
fans were going to continue reading they
were going to keep reading why wouldn't
they they've been reading for 30 years
you know they probably continue reading
even longer at least that was the
perspective of DC you know um and so it
you know rebooting it every year you
know rebooting makes makes perfect sense
so um let's see thoughts on flash TV
show the flash TV show is actually
pretty awesome like I really enjoy it
yeah see new 52 is great that's what I'm
saying like you know people will say the
new 52 is amazing some will say the new
52 sucks you know and see that's the
funny thing so okay so here's the here's
a question here's a really good example
alright oh yeah these are rings that we
got in me and Vinny got these in in
rhode island like this one is the Empire
Empire symbol and then this one is the
rebel alliance symbol so it's really
cool but anyway so so here's here's a
good example all right how many of you
okay what are you Ross thoughts opinions
but what are your all's opinions on the
new to to do you like it or do you hate
it and if you don't just say like I hate
it or I like it just this type like I
hate it or I like it yeah i mean i did a
video on valiant comics and then i'll
probably i may end up doing another
video like XO Manowar or something like
that you know experiment and see whether
or not you know that people would find
that more interesting so but that's why
they haven't gone all digital they are
afraid of losing the older loyal
audience well no it makes sense to not
go completely digital because of the
fact that you know their trades will
always sell there are always people who
want to just buy traits you want to
collect comic books you know that's
that's why they really not really
haven't gone digital so I like it I like
it I like it I like it no you don't even
read DC people like man I like it I hate
it you guys see what I mean people love
it people hate it it's a mixed bag you
made it in the Joker made it I like it's
a good starting point for new readers
it's a mixed bag new 22 man you guys see
what I mean you know there's no absolute
standard in the realm of comics there's
no definitive answer to what's good and
what's bad there's something just what
people like so is the injustice prequel
comic considered no injustice is a
totally isolated continuity it's
completely separate from the new 52 in
my video about injustice I explain a lot
of that stuff I talk about how its
separate how what it was based on why
was me that kind of thing
so um let's see do I think Supreme
Leader Snoke is Darth Plagueis that
would be a cool concept but he literally
remakes himself using the midi-chlorian
well rooted corners don't really exist
see midi-chlorians were a mixed SAR
weird ground here if you read the book
absolutely everything you need to know
about Star Wars make reference medic
lorians but JJ Abrams says we're not
going to be referencing there will be no
mention of midi-chlorians and that
doesn't mean they don't exist if
somebody just means they're not going to
talk about them so you know it's like do
they exist do they not exist no one's
provided an answer to that so you
actually started reading Batman again
within game yeah in game was really
really good let's see ya injustice is
okay and justice is pretty interesting I
guess it's not bad at all did you enjoy
doing the blue oval yeah the blue mobile
video was pretty fun it was pretty
interesting I like those concepts that
have historical context that are rooted
in the history of things those are the
kind of topics that I enjoy so injustice
is the zone so pious own separate
universe Nivens who got rid of a lot of
characters that people like to know they
just change the characters people like
they didn't get rid of them Batman is
still there Superman's still there
Wonder Woman Aquaman the Green Lantern
they're all still there no Wally West is
still there he's just different than the
character that you're used to is all it
is you know it's not the same character
that you remember you know and and so
yeah and that's this that's gonna be the
funny thing is in 10 years there's going
to be people who there's going to be
these these you know debates raging all
the infi to wally west is the best
version you know and then people are
going to say no the pre new 52 Wally
West is the best version and it's just
going to turn into this great big huge
debate so
I mean I'm trying to grow that it's
growing slow you know I've never tried
to grow up here before so I don't even
know if it'll grow any more than this to
be honest you know um let's see no all
the Batman continuities still the same
and I'll just happen in five years so
let's see are there any video game video
comics I can look at uh like motion
comics I'm not sure will Thor and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe become a rune
King to Avengers that would be not so
he's like ruined king for like stupidly
powerful I don't know he was only ruined
King Thor for like a really small period
of time for like 2 issues hmm it wasn't
as though it was like a major part of
his history so I have no idea Batman has
powers is called the powers of the
writer something my throat I was sitting
with the windows open last night and I'm
my beak Asian coming down with a cold so
it got down to like 30 degrees or
something like that last night but I
sleep like I love it being cold and
that's mostly doing was cold so um let's
see
uh Marvel hurt your wallet I feel you
man five years does not make any sense
oh I never said it made sense I never
said that everything like Batman from
his first appearance up until now
happened in five years I never said that
made sense I agree with you it's a
stupid experience stupid explanation but
it's the only explanation they gave us
and so we just kind of have to accept it
or or yeah we just gonna have to accept
that it's true because they're going to
be referencing things from that
continuity so um let's see Adam warlock
died can see Avengers against Thanos
sent Avengers annual number seven I have
not read that i do not know the answer
to your question the i prefer i prefer
being cold over being warm too yeah
that's my thing why not turn on the AC
well why use the air conditioner wagon
is open a window that does make any
sense motion comics okay you don't like
to be much reading but you'd like to
catch up on some comics motion comics
you can find like Superman red Sun I've
thought about doing motion comics to be
honest but I have no idea how what the
process is I have no idea how it works
you know I don't know how motion comics
function or like how they're made so I
mean I'll probably look into it because
I think motion comics would be a really
cool idea if any of you guys know how
long okay do you guys know how motion
comics are done like how people make
motion comics I'm kind of curious
let's see in comics what case what
caused me for YouTube um the flash went
back in time and tried to stop the death
of his mother and in the process
rebooted the continuity I know it's
weird but basically like like him going
back and trying to keep it's it's it's
weird basically flashpoint cause the
reboot of the Marvel Universe it's it's
more than I can explain in this single
in the single Q&A session I mean if I if
I were to explain flashpoint to you I
basically ignore everybody else's
questions and for the rest of this Q&A
and I don't want to do but but simply
put it was flashpoint flash went back in
time tried to save his mother
successfully saved her life cause the
flashpoint universe went back in time
stopped himself from saving his mother
and then DC used that to reboot the the
DC continuity so let's see Loki and
their blood brothers motion comics okay
I didn't does that exist you know I
don't I don't know do you read image a
great image story is we stand on guard
no I haven't really read image comics
that much I don't have a video that
flash but well I have a video about like
the new 52 but I haven't of the video
explicitly about flashpoint so let's see
archie comics are funny um am I Beatles
fan not no not really what am i what am
I this is actually this is e cigarette
this is a vape i'm vaping at the moment
uh where is my regular atomizer is what
i want to know where did I put it maybe
I put it back over there somewhere
maybe it's in my bed I don't know I put
it somewhere don't know where it is
not while my juices that's weird but
anyway um damn I don't know where I put
the damn thing house mouse that sex but
anyway um let's see where should you
start reading if you want to pick up new
Marvel The Legend of blue marble I mean
that's pretty much like that's when he
was first introduced after that he was
featured a few times and mighty avengers
and a handful of other stories but that
was really about it you know why do you
vape because I love the way the juice
juices tastes like they taste really
amazing so with all the indie comics out
there where the superhero age of movies
ends I mean it'll never end like I mean
there's there's always going to be
content to make a movie on there's
always going to be content to talk about
with regards to comic books I'm
refilling my e-cigarette real quick guys
so you so give me one second but um
let's see Phil Phil Phil come on thing
takes forever John Cena took it John
Cena busted in here and took my my
atomizer irda let's see cosmic entities
in the MCU too late to explain decent
manner not really we just don't know a
whole lot about him I mean you know in
my video who made the Marvel Universe or
who made the Infinity stones like that
is basically about as far as we get in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
regards to the the the cosmic entities
so
please give you guys my thoughts on the
jessica jones TV series we'll probably
do some jessica jones stuff here next
little bit or so but um but yeah I'm
actually really looking forward to it
I'm really excited to see where it goes
I mean I think it'll be pretty pretty
strong pretty solid in my address and
files fan now I mean I know butcher is
like well I guess what your dresden
files is really really popular but no
I've never I've never really been able
to get into it let's see fury as a
watcher no thanks too much Frank Lloyd
Richards versus the unbeatable squirrel
grow who would win the unbeatable
squirrel by a long shot do you see
interest in the Marvel movie universe
ending after infinity wars not really
because a question everybody is going to
have is where do we go from here and so
people are going to be really curious
for the first few films to see what what
Marvel does I'm actually really curious
to see what Marvel does like i Mun
wondering where they where do they go
from infinity wars or do they to say
like okay the model somatic universe has
done now that's it it was only going to
be three phases so
what do I think about vendetta's Green
Lantern and the flash or vinda tease on
you know Vin de tease flashes okay I'm
not the biggest fan of it but you know
it's it's decent enough my thoughts on
dark side war at the moment dark side
war is actually pretty interesting it's
pretty solid you know I'm pretty
interested to see where things go I mean
I don't want to spoil anything for you
guys but I'm like for those are you guys
who have read it I'm really interested
to see what they do with the joburg like
I'm one hundred percent sure that's the
Joker I could be wrong but I'm very sure
that's the Joker so um let's see
favorite villain doomsday Thanos dark
side are you asking me or you are you
rob explains Rev explains for video
incursions in the MCU that would be a
cool concept that would be a really cool
idea for face for like the incursions
are happening the world's crowd like
alternate realities crashing into each
other because they can depict like all
these different versions and then they
could just reboot everything like that
would be a really cool concept let's see
who do I like more doctor stranger
Constantine Doctor Strange definitely
but just just because of the fact that
he has such an immersive world in terms
of like it's not just about fighting
demons like I so it's about finding you
know magical creatures of all kinds and
to me that's really really fascinating
so well I do an explain video on cam
Lacan a camila con yet probably you know
a lot of the more popular characters
from like the headlining characters from
all different marble I'll probably do
stories on so like comic-con miss marvel
different things like that like I'll do
a video on her most likely so how are
you liking the new Marvel content any
must buys in your opinion oh yeah like
the must buys for for Marvel right now
or Doctor Strange is a really good one
invincible Iron Man is a really good one
if you're a fan of spider-man all new
amazing spider-man is a good one if
you're not a big fan you can probably
steer clear of it but there are
references to what's going on and the
spider-man comics and so you may want to
buy it just for the sake of knowing of
having like a complete idea of
everything that's taking place
Deadpool's a mess why because it's
really cool is this it's a great it's
such a great way to a well-written story
it's not the Goofy's any Deadpool
instead it is it's a a more serious and
it can be a take on Deadpool the if the
deadpool comic is written more like a
like a comic you could like a comic to
some part with everything else instead
of Deadpool being an outlier where the
comic is just out there in left field
you know it is a comic that is it feels
like the rest of the Marvel Universe if
that makes sense all me Wolverine is a
really good one and there's a handful of
others too let's see do you think
they're actually going to make a
financially for sequel oh I guarantee
Fox is going to make another Fantastic
Four movie um why wouldn't they they
don't know what's going
um no one is ever equal to Superman oh
uh let's see favorite Deadpool story
Deadpool kills the marvel universe my
favorite Deadpool story by a long shot
what happened to Iron Man liquid silver
suit uh that's never explained it's just
a suit that he doesn't use anymore you
know bindus never answers that question
it's just like he had a superior iron
man but now he doesn't and we don't know
why so I don't know the answer to that
question do I have roommates no I live
in a little studio apartment like no I
don't have a roommate let's see Rob let
me tell you how Austin Texas is the best
place in the world for barbecue I'll
take your word for it let's see mm-hmm
can I do an explain video for Aquaman oh
yeah well definitely because I like the
character explanations you know I like
doing the new 52 character explanations
like that's really fun and plus well
that's being you know two or three years
into the into the characters you know
doing the new 52 is actually really
enjoyable for me like it's it's really
really fun so let's see uh is a new
uncanny Avengers but good yeah it's
really good actually with that it's
really really entertaining it's fun it's
a it's a fun interesting it's just a fun
book you know and that's what I'm glad
about is you know um Marvel is combining
you know comedy with seriousness you
know you have serious stories but you
also have hilarious and funny stories
and that's what they need you know
coming out of time runs out coming out
of Secret Wars like we need some comedy
you know and especially like in the
world we live in now you know in this
day and age you know how many books are
a great way to find that find that you
know I'm going to make that might make a
video why do people love why do people
like comic books but you know it's it's
a great way
Texas is okay that guy gets the
banhammer um no it's a great way to to
break away from the monotony of everyday
life and and just experience something
new so let's see if I haven't read 100
bullets no I've never read 100 bullets
if Jim Jasper's can't create things out
of nothing can he create a whole
universe like Franklin Richards well I
mean assuming he doesn't really well he
can to a degree but that's never been
demonstrated and in the end all we can
do is go through the context of the
comics when when Franklin created the
universe who created a universe that was
like a pocket universe like ace like
literally ace miniature universe there's
no reason to believe Jim Jasper's
couldn't do the same thing you know he
just never did in his stories so who got
banned some guy who was insulting
somebody else's yeah and suddenly
somebody else well it's look guys I mean
you know these q and A's are fun you
know and the only thing I ask your
during these q and A's is that you guys
treat people with respect you know
that's that's the only thing I ask you
on my channel you know treat people with
respect and you'll be treated with
respect you know if you treat people
with disrespect you're going to get
banned and that's all there is to it so
um let's see Jasper's requires your
universe to exists for him to manipulate
it exactly well Joker remember Batman's
identity I don't know um let's see
here's the kicker guys when it comes to
DC at the moment DC is focusing on
stories as opposed to continuity and so
like dark side war for example you know
Darkseid war will likely feature the
Joker will likely bring the Joker into
the forefront and the question becomes
this you know what's what you know who's
who and in terms of the Joker you know
is the Joker will the Joker remember
everything you know when does Darkseid
Wars take place you know that's that's
the big issue here is DC is not
establishing when darkside war takes
place maybe dockside war takes place
after Batman in game maybe takes place
before Batman
we don't know the answer to that
question so you know when does Superman
truth take place does it take place
before dark side war does it take place
after dark side war you know the answer
to that question is not given here so
let's see except the Fox no respect all
right I'm going to answer a couple more
questions guys and then I'm going to
bounce off here but yeah creativity over
continuity exactly which i think is
actually good call it's better to create
good stories and not worry about
continuity than to create subpar stories
while worrying about continuity you know
it's a classic question of a doctor you
know I mean who would you rather have a
doctor that ignores you while you get
better or a doctor that you know sits at
your side while you can get worse you
know I mean I guess I guess it would
really suck to have a doctor that
ignores you while you get worse but
that'd be really messed up but
nonetheless like that's that's that's
kind of how this the example goes so um
let's see have I red black vortex now I
haven't read black vortex a lot of the
stuff you know is in my opinion then
here's here's where things lie you know
for those of you guys who are looking to
get into Marvel Comics right now your
best bet is to start with all new all
different Marvel with the all new all
different marble titles if those stories
reference previous events then you may
want to go ahead and start we you know
sort of start reading those if you are
you know if they don't reference
previous events then don't worry about
them and that's kind of my philosophy
you know so which is kind of tie into
old things as they tie in so but yeah
let's see love that you finally made it
on here I rock well I appreciate that
but like you actually made it at the
last minute because I'm getting ready to
wrap this up um let's see
thoughts on T may be aware that like I
said guys you know I mean it takes me
about 17 hours to make a video that's 20
minutes long so I just want to really
make those videos that long anymore but
I haven't had time to read a lot of new
publications so if they're not a central
I haven't have really had time to read
them that much so um but uh yeah so
anyway guys um we're going to go ahead
and wrap this up we're going to go ahead
bring this to an end but but uh yeah so
I will yeah I guess I'm going to go get
some energy drinks get gassed up and get
to work on making these I guess you know
putting together the all new all
different Wolverine and all new all
different Deadpool videos so yeah I will
catch you guys later peace crab there it
is